voodoo Power
eri Japan
Discrimination Japowai Tanaka Town
Come on First A West f 3 s to me
par Early Creation Audi Stem
Well, the car arrested for that child's mode, but
salmon run is a new game that can be played by 2 to 4 people.
Introducing Mr. Kuma and effective Defeating 8 salmon from a mysterious organization and collecting how much are you
so are en do you do
steak naa into me to do When
you defeat a big salmon called big salmon that sometimes appears in a
gold  I'm going to drop how much, but the real purpose is to collect 8 how much of this money within the 8 time limit
.
Even if I'm doing this
, the color to crack the day before is enough. Business style
Ah, within the time limit 8 r Ah ah Nude player is eh keeper 4th place kei
e
buster do do
Pod = lowest or petite pr corner
[applause]
Boo Boo some Collaborate with your allies to increase their missions
Foreplay cb 2 Good t 6 s 0 a 4 m Smoother
If you do it, you'll be a land lieutenant
Salmon Randy is that online play and online play
There is
to do the birth noborder game
osono Yes, what I'm showing you today is offline salmon, so the local
multiplayer souvenirs of Banya are also guards.
The
online salmon run is a request from the introduction of Koma-san, and as the sake
goes up the river, it occurs like a meeting and an event.  Masu
voodoo
Boo Boo sore to do
bbsmaster
Boo Boo cheering a prayer Nu saraki
Daddy usually
that is good
Until for some reason Japan can be the first if you do not destroy the putter of your head
etc and stun sa Pakusei manager  That's
forever Manuelme  Computer Cellar Medium I
told you to fight with a long-range weapon, so
I'm gonna guide you
usaki Ross Marlen
you do Kines Perth mangas Farmers Club 4 ae Ah
Herb 1 Ah Ah Ah
First anus Coverhouse ester Di
Booby Weapon together oo Cocoa myself
Pou dou dou The
first webber has started voodoo vibe 4 f
head ap 2
Oh now 3 can be easted a little while coordinating such things well.
Look for that keeper sound. I
'd like to say that Nakata Passport, another aiesec that appeared over there at the party
.
[Applause]
voodoo But the number of shots s Ah
ah that noranero timesten
Warpburn ter
There are two computers, so my friends  Then I think it's on the
computer on the right.
Ore is the pump on the left. Put in the Japanese vote. All 4 n That cooperation, that Spaty-
chan Yoshi.
From to next
nus nus You guys are doing a great job
re me you do New
nos
I expected this guy to feel like this I
cleared it Pew do
tree part a f
Brown 10 selections Chainpusen  I'm going to go, I
'll clear it with a pure difficulty level at 10%
Yes, that difficulty level is uh, that's right, that pitch black Karma city
can be set freely by that player.
I will go without setting the width to 85% or 100%
voodoo
rear shock to do over her Wow Leslie Mare
spara nox springs of a Border Wien Spoon Ah
, I would like to challenge with 30% from now on, but before that
Well
, why don't we talk about the new elements that Tsumugi didn't have in this mode called Thermandran?
Although it is a game mainly online that was released in 8 bu,
I thought that I would like to focus on Aso's local multiplayer because it will be released on Nintendo Switch
re Ale
[Applause]
kr 0  Speeder Chopper
I'll explain a little about the dividends as a group, but this sometimes happens like this.
I collaborate with Matty, who is 8th in the voodoo area.
[Applause]
Harlem You can give a pure nude sign directly. A little
laser coaster Fumofuwato uc 2
Boo Boo saying here on Till who found Charko.
[Applause]
I played the web ni web version that you can breathe.
00 Saha It's already fierce. Yeah,
then I'll give you two explanations for the faction
.  In the local multi of the head, the eight people gathered to increase that opportunity to play.
Splatoon is also a team battle, so there is of course fun to cooperate with,
but since it is a zero-sum game, it is a game that you
buy from here and lose.
The main of the rose is also tipo and Moses and the tuner with Mr. Cho and the offense and defense jun
middle
pou
dou dou If you cooperate, it will be stronger.  I've cleared it. Well, Ichi Melos are you do
web fashion stor Yeah,
that's the limit of that money.
If you are asked to do it, it will be
done in the form of a part-time job.  If you clear that part-time job, for
example, it's a specially designed gear or
something like that.
I was a little convinced that it was a little bit
convinced.
render
r
4ds asaden Wyarm Funny Face Marketer Derailleur
Pump up 8 patterns are planned to pump up through
, so
it's a story when it comes to starting, but I'd like to hear
that new species of salmon now.  It's Shinshu when it's newly discovered, but what kind of
creature is it? Yes
Boo Boo Ring Blue Polar Letter Pon All Par 4
has undergone its own evolution and can move numerical fish that move underwater.
You can also work on land
ana Ale
Oppa This is also an event, isn't
it singing in that analysis, isn't it?
There is no
ste ah wow
re not to do It seems that we will
cooperate more with each other Even if the player who has improved his skills in the rematch
does not cooperate, this will still be cleared but do sev Fuel Corporation
acu uno and ah
4 stormy love japan Mother  Corporation are to do
me I'll continue to explain a little about the future. The
destination is that Eto
ki ra ri ki,
isn't it
?  The amount of noodles in Kairyu's curved Kyunyo farm-
render agent ana 10 re yo  u doing
endeavor offer
English type 4 so the purpose of the request from the par 3 introduction is to collect the age of the child
hi there flame party etc.
[Applause]
Soccer Hokkaido Himachi
Kusukuri Please tell me if there is anything in the future. Good luck
again.
It's 80%
, but it's a good house, not a starter
. It's
full of shapes that you can go back one step and set again a little.
Once you clear it, if you continue to smoke it, it will increase by 5%
.
Voodoo is 100%, but
if you continue to use it, it will increase your mind by 105% 110% 115%.  I'll go with a
stool spray sr f
hde one to do It will rise to 200%, so
players who are confident in their arms should definitely challenge
rear derailleur
100% perso rear derailleur to dad
.  Please help the lighting from the front and your friends immediately.
So if 4 people are defeated, you will lose, so you need to survive as much as possible.
Ray finereader Puffa
Defense to do
By the way, other chairs here Weapons used here  It's basically the
same as the one used in that match. That name Yoneya f Seguma
meus garena Then, Toyama's original Toyama was there. The sub-weapon can nest with a splash bomb by playing
[Applause]
usaron.  I
'm pure head call this theme is line y Far I've achieved my goal
so only two blues escape. Speaking of the pouring station
Mach I
managed to survive early
andere Diplomacy at the bar
[Applause]
Patty Surfres Very 4
usa Ale The explanation was in the middle, but so head  There's a pock on top,
but
one more player can do a special iphone only twice per player through the three
webs.
sure do do to
special sloper 3 part agb play defeat Think carefully where to use
[applause]
Hmm us are lesson mama ni Tonihoi-san left mousse pearl and 240 ah
Epra 3 along with something Quick-drying disappears
There are two tips for the sound of playing. Ah,
6 cars
rus The henro figure has broken down
.
It ’s okay
, please choose that one. Well, let ’s clear it 80%
.
You can make various types of entries, so balance them with your friends as a
whole. Pops finale per me baby Hard goods
play
render are you do is a shallow line before the start.
That's vr might be you do me
before sterlingness?
ender ender ender star
[applause]
Let's do our best
[music]
Buber leisure expenses
It's an event
Salmon rush s Living in Benz m without s
already kemang Cure ticky That golden color Already that sake is mixed with Osaki
Hyper trust distribution is possible
Pirin Lesser mousse ml Small cover This winter b
Well flying here  There is only one player in the player who has a golden applause to go to the light of the house
.
Voodoo Moose rba Effector should also go to the satellite
Get Rapifa Passion number
[Applause]
[Music]
voodoo sa
Ah ah me Taste a few minutes Mach Ma Voice Fine
Boo Boo s Arm Stopper
Good herb nuno Push bar Bisping Broforce
[Music]